much needed humanitarian Aid arriving at
Port Sudan it includes medical supplies
from Qatar and Egypt
This Plane carries Aid needed for
surgeries amid the current situation in
Sudan there is some medicine blood
donation bags and Trauma kits again I
thank the Qatari government
Sudanese Army and the rapid support
forces is concentrated in the Triangle
of the capital Khartoum bahri not of the
capital and umdurman across the Nile
River
the Army says it's pushed back the
paramilitary group from omdurman a city
across the Nile from Khartoum It also
says troops targeted a number of Rebel
positions in the center and north of the
capital resulting in heavy losses
including weapons and vehicles
but the rapid support forces is claiming
victory in the north saying it's gained
control of several military bases the
group has released footage which it says
shows the capture of 700 soldiers
the ongoing violence has caused a major
humanitarian crisis today 25 million
people more than half the population of
Sudan need human Aid and protection this
is the highest number we have ever seen
in the country many people say the
situation is unbearable there is no
shelter we have no family to stay with
we can't go back to our homes we don't
know which state is safe to go
we can't endure it any longer war and
destruction we can't sleep because of
the mosquitoes we want to leave this
place for a safer area
the violence has also spread to the
Western Darfur region with the worst
fighting happening in genea more than
300 people are reported to have been
killed in a matter of days
negotiations towards a ceasefire and a
safe passage for refugees are continuing
in Jeddah Saudi Arabia Al jazeera's
diplomatic sources say the warning sides
are holding unofficial talks through
mediators
foreign